and you forget you come back you go open
your email and boom you hear
ray's been shot
well thanks hulu like
great great let me also this is a
disclaimer i don't work for any of these
companies i don't know any of their code
this is truly just me as a consumer uh
me and my grievances hello everybody my
name is nyan i'm the black female
engineer i provide content for new and
aspiring software engineers and today we
are talking about some companies that uh
need to fix a few things in their code
this these are things that i've just
been thinking about for like up to a
year every time i see something pop up
and whatnot and i i just get it just
irks me and it's funny because it very
much is that software developer
mind uh in me because now i do certain
things and i'm like wow they should
really change their code for x y and z
let me know in the comments below what
things you notice and what things you
agree with and what things you don't and
so first of all let's start with
mercedes benz i got a new car recently
about uh three months ago and it is a
mercedes benz i am very happy
about it because it was a goal i've had
for the last like eight years and so i
was really really happy that i finally
got to do it there's this specific thing
that happens though with my car so i
have the gla 250 and one thing that was
very important to me was the speaker
system of the car i was getting when i
was looking at new cars and testing your
cars and everything i would put the
volume up try to see like oh he doesn't
have a good base does it have good
surround sound and whatnot can we feel
good going to the club in this car and
that is true
however my car does the specific thing
where you're listening to a song right
and then let's say you're trying to skip
songs so you're listening to a song and
you press that like fast 40 button or
the next button on the display where it
typically says the artist the song title
and all that
when you click next
now on the display it says
track
plus one
and then it goes to the next track
now i don't know if y'all are thinking
what i'm thinking
but i'm thinking someone left a print
statement
somewhere in there in their code someone
left a console log
somewhere um because to me that's not
what it should do because that's what
the code is doing it's looking at the
track which is i in my opinion track is
equal to the certain the the current
song playing and then
on click on click of this button on
click do track plus one and it goes to
the next track and so that's how imagine
the code is working out i think someone
left a console log somewhere there
because i shouldn't
see that because you don't have to tell
me that it's going to track plus one or
the next song but if you wanted to like
let's say the programmers really were
like no we need to show them that you
know we are sticking with what they want
us to do and we are going to the next
track then ideally what you would say is
display on the screen playing next track
or skipping or next you wouldn't put
track plus one it's literally track
plus one i'll try to add a picture
somewhere around here or video or of
some kind so if someone working at
mercedes is watching this video please
uh update that and when you do
let me know so i can put my car up and
we can we can fix all that next company
on the list is bumble yes bumble the
dating app meant for like women to take
the first move which is a whole thing in
itself but that's let's talk for another
day in bumble
this is super recent i started noticing
this only about two weeks ago because i
know this wasn't a thing but true before
then now
if you have matches right like matches
in your page race you see like okay i
have matches with like let's say these
three people despite having these
matches set you may still want to swipe
and see what other matches you get just
you know because it's a free country
bumble now
has it so
that if you're swiping and you have
matches like matches waiting is what uh
i believe the exact term they use if
you're swiping after like your tenth
swipe-ish um in your current session
it will pop it'll like interrupt you and
like put up this pop-up and be like hey
you have matches waiting how about you
go message those people like
like if you don't get the if you don't
get out and let me continue my swiping
i'm going to throw like i'm going to
throw you away like i can't stand that
like i'll be just like in a rhythm right
and then just like
alert like the if you've seen the circle
it's like alert and like you have
matches waiting i just feel so judged
almost like you have matches waiting
like what what the hell are you doing
swiping all up in here like can you not
tell me what to do and like i'm making
this way deeper than it is but it's just
something that annoys me a lot and i'm
sure this is all done within some type
of if statement like if user has matches
but is swiping
after 10 swipes
insert this alert how about we take that
whole part out like if these are swiping
leave them alone like let's
let's just not and so yes that is my
grievance number two that is yeah with
bumble and then last but certainly not
least because this is something that has
been bothering me for years years years
because this has always been a thing
with hulu i don't know if other people
have noticed this but hulu right and
there to be honest on this there are a
couple of things um
that should be fixed uh with hulu's app
but again that's a conversation for a
different day this specific thing
however i can't let go any longer
on hulu if you're watching a show right
say you're watching you know the good
doctor which i've actually been watching
a ton if you you know follow me on
instagram you know that follow me on
instagram by the way it's at the black
female engineer but yes anyway if you
are watching a show say the good doctor
and
let's say you pre you put pause right
you click pause uh because you realize
you need to go do some other things you
click pause put your laptop away and go
hop in your mercedes to go on the bumble
date you just scheduled so you come back
this is hours later it was a good day
you come back
and you turn on your laptop and you're
trying to just uh let's say you write an
email you turn on your laptop you go to
your email and you start hearing
something you start hearing like
dialogue and whatnot you realize
it's the good doctor playing
why is a good doctor playing it's on
pause you're on pause why are you
playing i'm not even on the screen
hulu somewhere on somewhere on line 652
of media dot p y
they have
and you know this just be speculating
a function and actually it wouldn't even
be like media.py it'd be like media.js
uh the code i'm thinking
they have a line of code that's that
that says
on page load window.onload i think is
the exact syntax like window.onload
play
because
simply by you turning on your computer
and your browsers are like really
loading um like turning on because yeah
you've been gone for a while
hulu starts playing the show you are on
this it doesn't matter if you put pause
on it it doesn't matter if you didn't
put pause on it doesn't matter if when
you open your laptop you're on the excel
spreadsheet or you open your laptop and
now you're on hulu
no matter what on page load
the media starts playing
why why
why
like i can't stand this and let's say
what if you had paused it before this
like super good scene that you were like
you know what like i need to go on this
date so let me wait to reveal
who you know is about to get murdered or
whatever now i guess we're not talking
about the good doctor this is i don't
know how to get away with murder but let
me pause before i see who gets murdered
let me run to this date and you know
when i come back and everything and you
forget you come back you go open your
email and boom you hear
ray's been shot
thanks hulu like
it's great great like now i don't even
need to put play again and watch you so
another one i don't know why i'm getting
so actually i do know why i'm getting so
worked up with this because i truly find
it absurd i
hate this part of hulu so much and it's
funny because now i am working in the
media realm and yeah there's a lot that
comes into um yeah making apps like this
and everyday and so please know that i
am not uh trying to say that anyone is a
bad developer or you know y'all working
hard like i know believe me i know this
is just a fun light-hearted video where
i just share a few things in hopes that
maybe
something gets fixed like a one percent
hope that someone's watching this who
can actually address these matters but
really just to
all in all share that yeah when you
have a profession when you spend 40
hours a week doing something you start
seeing the world a lot differently you
start thinking about the code that goes
into the daily things you
love and the technologies you use and
everything it's very interesting i
imagine if you're a barista and you make
all these coffees all the time you now
have a very specific taste when it comes
to coffee and you know that oh they use
the one percent milk instead of two
percent and everything like you just
start knowing these things and so it's
very funny um to see that that is what
has become of me please let me know what
things you agreed with what things you
didn't uh what things you maybe didn't
notice before but now that i said it you
see it or notice it and yeah just your
thoughts if there are other companies
that you have thoughts like this with
please please please let me know in the
comments because i'd love to get that
like fun dialogue going and maybe make
this uh more into like more videos and
do like part two part three part four so
let me know in the comments below but
don't forget to subscribe and like the
video and i will see you all later bye